my original teacher was Jim Rohn when I
met him when I was 17. and I wanted to
know why all my fathers were broke
because they were good men you know I
loved all four of my fathers and I
remember him saying Tony we're all equal
as Souls
but we're not equal in the marketplace I
was like what does that mean and he said
well think about it he goes you need to
become more valuable
if you want to have economic freedom he
said you have to work on yourself more
than anything else and you have to work
on in a way where there's something you
can do for others better than anyone
else or at least more a better quality
and he gave me an example of like
working at McDonald's and he said you
know if you work at McDonald's you make
whatever it was in those days five
dollars an hour whatever it was and I go
yeah but that seems so unfair and he
goes yeah and teachers I give example of
teachers and there's these billionaires
you know that make a billion dollars in
a year hedge fund guy you know and he
said Tony the guy you just mentioned he
provided a 40 return last year and that
went to non-profits everything else he
said that means those organizations
double their money almost every two
years he is adding massive value
hundreds of billion dollars they made a
billion he goes this person is doing a
job that anyone can learn in 20 minutes
or half a day so it's a beginning job he
said you got you got to think of it as
one thing it's all about adding value
how can you do more for others than
anybody else in the world and that stuck
with me I mean I was like I decided I
wanted to do more friends than anybody
in the world in order to do that I had
certain skills and I went after those
skills and I still do it like it's a
never-ending thing if you think you're a
master you're full of it right so I
think that's probably some of the best
advice I've received at least on life
and business and Direction and it
affected my mission hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's have
your best believe life and watch some
powerful inspiring speeches
speech number two is operate above your
potential with Grant Cardone every time
my mom was my best friend and every time
I would have a success it didn't matter
whether I was 18 years old or 48 years
old anytime I had a success she was the
first person I called I wouldn't call a
girlfriend wouldn't call my wife
wouldn't call any of the people that
were closest to me I called my mom said
mom you never believe I just bought a
real estate deal I started this company
I bought my first real estate deals 38
units it's four million dollars and
she'd be like that's awesome I love you
Just the Way You Are
and I'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you I love you that's great
that's great you made 160 Grand last
year
but I love you just the way you are let
me hear that okay that's right out of
the 10x rule I don't know if you know
that that's right out of the four
actions
anybody know what action is
average average I'm doing well okay
there's four levels of action number one
is I do nothing
if I rewrote this book I would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all is impossible try doing
it right now
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true I wouldn't put
it in the book If I rewrote it the
second level of action is uh to retreat
this is what most people do by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay okay
I was up late whatever you came up with
whatever reason I'm gonna make
the life any single Retreat is a
discipline and a commitment
to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware that what are you
doing here okay there's only four things
you can do in any given day right you
could do nothing you could Retreat or
you could do this average
now I know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the top you're the best you made
it to Miami but I'm just going to tell
you right now ain't not a person in this
room is above number three
no I'm not there okay and I know how
much I'm grinding every day how much I'm
pushing every day how how many how many
hours I put into a day what's the
maximum number of hours you can do in a
day not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th Thing Once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with Solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay here
there's a bunch of people in the room
that
that like I don't know anything about
technology
I'm 61 years old I was born in 1958. I
am supposed to be outside of that moment
of Technology yet I'm probably one of
the top five social media people in the
world today
banging on Instagram and Snapchat and
Linkedin and Google Plus that'll go away
using all these mechanisms to try to get
attention so that I can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man I'd write the book If I wrote the
book I'd write it 11x
I'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is a hundred
okay so what what I do what I did in it
when Lehman collapsed I wrote the 10x
Rule and I wrote the book because I
realized I had done something wrong that
book was written for me and the reason
when I closed the book The reason I was
like ah whatever I had figured out what
I had done wrong okay I had to embrace
the the the idea that three or four
million dollars in a bank and a house
paid for and two cars and a marriage and
I got it better than everybody else and
my mama loves me just the way I am was
all this this middle class in America
the middle class it is the sleeping
chamber
on planet Earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from India and China come to
here to get a middle class and I don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world
you might change your house you might
change the education your little kids
get okay they get to go to Texas A M big
deal right he told me that he went to
Texas I said oh that had to screw you up
back just going to college
wow because what are they manufacture in
college
they manufacture average people at
college
so so I want to challenge you today okay
I want to challenge you today I want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am I even a top
producer
how did that get created for this room
what number did you have to hit to get
in this room what's the number a million
who made that number up was that Bob
I'm Bob Bob sitting around what can we
do what can we do okay all right did he
make the number one million up
why wasn't it one million one hundred
thousand one ten one one one instead
because he got lazy
one million
would agree with that
It's a lazy number do anything that ends
in a zero is lazy
come on how about some creativity
right how about a little creativity when
you're when you're making decisions in
your life like what's a good income
level for this room let's say we don't
share this anywhere outside this room
what would be what would be a real
number you guys are going to hire me
what's a real number that I can make in
this room
y'all can talk to me
God damn I I will not hurt you okay
what's a number 400 Grand okay now why
do we come up with that number
because I don't know how you guys could
even live on that number
[Music]
if if I made 400 Grand a year I would be
embarrassed with myself as a husband a
father basically as a human being
400 Grand how do you make sense of 35
000 a month
you guys haven't done the math
you have not done the math because you
cannot live on 400 Grand a year
and if you think you can live on 400
Grand a year
I might have to go back and add number
one
[Music]
nothing
anybody can make 400 Grand a year all
you got to do is show up
okay now I don't know if I don't know if
I'm right or wrong you guys don't need
to agree with me I've already been paid
my fee okay I am not here to satisfy you
I am not here so you like oh oh green I
like him I don't care if you like me or
not man I want to move a handful of
people in the room to go from 400 Grand
a year to start thinking about how do I
make 4 million big boy right over here
popping out what do you what did you
make last year
what'd you gross last year
2.7 how does anybody live on 2.7 million
dollars a year
[Music]
simple dude I cannot I can't my my plane
eats 2.7 million dollars a year this
dude needs to think different he's
running out of time man you guys all in
the room man you're running out of time
you're in a space that is so frothy with
opportunity it's unbelievable you're
making sense of less than you can get
this is my mama my mama's saying I love
you boy just the way you are Mama I made
10 million dollars on one deal that's
great but son I love you just the way
you are I'm like I don't love me just
the way I am because I'm doing deals
where I know I could make a hundred
okay how many of you in the room are
operating below your potential let me
see a hand if you know you're operating
below your potential man please tell me
you're operating how how many of you let
me see your hand again if you're
operating below your potential
okay your finances should indicate that
your finances are a way to tell the
truth about who you are your space like
if you're an Uber driver and you're
making 2.7 million a year
pat on the back
you're in this space making 2.7 million
here come on man your company's doing
what 2 billion
two billion dollars and you guys aren't
getting it all would you say that you're
not getting it up
[Music]
a lot of room he's telling me he's in
the first Innings of his game so so I'm
like hey what what do I need to do let's
say 400 is the number then I'm gonna
take this and I'm just going to 10x that
and I'm gonna build a business plan for
four million dollars
and I'm gonna quit thinking I'm gonna
quit thinking that I that I got to do a
four minute mile
I'm gonna quit thinking about the
physical Universe what can I do to
produce four million dollars Worthy
is it here is it outside of here is it
here and outside of here how many
customers would I need this is what this
is what my goal for you today is to
leave here and say dude I ain't
satisfied okay I want to raise the
numbers on this room so the next time
there's 75 people here and everybody
adds a zero to your income oh by the way
if you love yourself at 400 Grand mama
if you love your son just the way he is
at 400 would you love me a little more
if I add a zero no she couldn't love me
anymore it wasn't up to her to love me
it was up to me to love what I'm doing
every day right you guys are showing up
you're working your ass off every day
right or wrong
how many of you make good calls every
day you're like I do not want to make
this call and you make it anyway good
then get paid for it
get paid some real money for it man okay
keep
how many calls would I have to make is
this even possible he's doing part of it
he told me I'm not he's not tapped into
all of it
he's hitting 70 percent of that number
if everybody walked out of here and said
hey I'm gonna build a four million
dollar plan I'm gonna tell you I'm gonna
tell you a little a little game I play I
got 14 little companies I run 14 little
companies while I'm doing deals while
I'm speaking to you today right I'm
still running them in my head right now
I got them all open I got browsers open
all over the place
counselor said you got add I said I
ain't got add I don't know how to add I
multiply
I'm done adding I'm done adding a
customer I want to multiply customs I
want to I don't want to add orders I
want to multiply my orders okay I
consider myself a decent salesperson but
it doesn't matter if you're a great
salesperson if you don't add business to
the sale if you don't become a business
person you can't build out zeros speech
number three is armor your mind with
David Goggins I am beyond excited to be
doing the second to go around with you
the first one for me was utterly
transformational just researching you
and the way that your mind works
I'm really I mean as evidenced by the
shirt that I'm wearing I really am that
guy that like put your picture up and it
was just became this reminder of of what
we can all do if we're willing to push
past that pain and all of that right but
speaking of pain I want to know why is
the book called can hurt me
there's some
I guess some inside views to people in
there but it's the overall message to
people that we're all you know a lot of
us are going through a hard time in life
some people have been bullied some
people are just stressed out some people
are insecure some people are fat and
overweight and the world puts a lot of
this in your mind
it's not just you yeah you help it and
my whole thing is about I had to develop
a mindset a mindset that was
indestructible I had to armor plate my
mind
and it's about what you're saying to
yourself but it also comes at work so
whenever I was getting beat down
physically mentally spiritually whatever
I was going through just saying you know
I would put you know you can't hurt me
can't hurt me just became a message I
you know I would say to myself
and that's just kind of where it comes
from what I find so interesting is your
concept of the governor that basically
out of the chills that an expert is
somebody who's going to tell you what
your limits are rather than the person
that's out there practicing getting you
beyond the limit so what is the governor
and how do we strip it out of our Lives
I believe that most human beings are
only living at about 40 percent of their
capability
so the mind has a governor like a car if
you're driving a car and the car has a
governor on it the car may say 130 miles
an hour but the governor said for 91.
once that Governor sets in you get the
91 that car starts doing this the car
wants to go the car wants to go but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91. we have a factory a nice governor in
our brain and it's the survival
mechanism it protects us from pain and
suffering the second we feel that our
mind says oh no this isn't fun we should
back off we should sit down find
something more comfortable and there's
something about the mind the mind has
the Tactical damage over you at all
times
at all times of your life the mind has a
tactical advantage over you why is that
it knows what you're afraid of it knows
your insecurities it knows your deep
dark lies and it starts to push you away
from that it pushes you in a direction
that is comfortable
the Mind controls everything so what I
realized was that when I was growing up
and I was 300 pounds and I got all fat
and I got all insecure I realized that
my mind kept taking me in this direction
when things got uncomfortable for me
when I was facing my insecurities I was
facing my fears my mind said oh no we
had a tactical Advantage we need to get
you separate you from this feeling this
feeling of your life is all about
feelings we want The Happy Feeling we
don't want that feeling of this sucks
why am I here and you don't have any so
so you can't answer those questions so
you leave
I started realizing that if in that
moment
you can answer those sub questions and
you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you that's
where all that stuff comes from so so
the 40 rule is all of that you get to 40
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is starting to get painful this
is uncomfortable so you sit down
you have to figure out ways and
everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know five
steps to this and four steps to this
it's a lot more than that that's all
[ __ ] it's it's a practice that you
have to it's a habit so if you know that
at 40 I'm still you know I'm feeling
pain at 40 I'm feeling pain that's where
the 40 rule kicks in now it starts okay
I'm feeling pain my mind's saying all
this to me is saying get out of here run
flee the fight or flight kicks in okay
we're done we're not good enough it
starts telling you all these things you
start to believe it because the mind
controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind it's okay let
me see if I can go 45 percent
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind start finding more
in you know in yourself and it goes from
40 it's a lot further than that but
that's the start of it though get to get
to the spot where your mind is saying
stop
wherever that is you gotta get there
first and then that's when that starts
to work for you you got to control
yourself in that moment also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there speech number four is build
resilience with Ed mylett all the people
that I've coached I'll have different
Talent skills and abilities what's the
one they all have the ability to stay
present the ability to stay in the fight
to have not quit you think well that's
not a big deal really because as I've
been talking millions of people made the
decision to quit on their dream just as
I've been talking to you the rest of the
day Millions more will tomorrow Millions
more every day literally millions of
people quit on one of their dreams their
dream relationship their dream business
their dream body so quitting has become
the number one Habit in the world by
people that end up losing and I'm
telling you it happens every day every
second everywhere just the fact that
while I've been speaking you're still
after your dream you're ahead of them
you don't give yourself enough credit
because eventually what I found it looks
like winnings this huge competition but
every day every week every year every
decade as time goes by you're gonna find
that you're competing with a smaller and
smaller and smaller group of people for
your dream because so many of them will
just quit and by the way many of them
that quit will possess talents maybe
even gifts you don't have their
incredible ability with people their
Incredible strength their incredible
brain and they'll quit with all this
giftedness but you got the talent you
have to learn to distinguish between
something that is a talent and a gift
you can develop skills you can develop
talents gifts are something you're born
with but the people that I see that win
long term are the ones who develop the
talents and skills required to win
business and Life's a lot like a pinata
you know I was at a barbecue a birthday
party for a five-year-old a while back
and they did a pinata have you seen the
pinata before and it's an unbelievable
metaphor for life in fact we ought to
call today the life is like a pinata
because it really is if you look at
these kids at these parties any of
you've ever been to a pinata you can
picture they got the pinata up there
what do they do it's just like in
business and life when you start
something new a new relationship a new
body a new Pursuit a new business right
what do they do they take this little
five-year-old and they blindfold them
they blindfold this little guy right and
he can't see he doesn't know where he's
going and then they spin him around he
gets completely disoriented right and
then they hand him a bat it's scary when
you watch it don't you picture these
little kids right you blindfold them
they spin around they become disoriented
does that sound familiar to any of you
that are trying to build a business
right now
you're completely disoriented you're
blind you don't know where to go they
spin this little guy around they hand
him a bat and they go hit the pinata and
the pinatas over to the right and
they're swinging to the left they're
just whiffing right they're not even in
the right direction and then finally
what do you do you grab the little guy
or the little girl and you turn them and
you have them face the pinata they were
completely different in fact they were
doing more damage to the people around
him in the beginning with that darn bat
you gave them because they're so
disoriented a lot of damage was done
before they even faced the actual pinata
they've been blindfolded and spun around
right they're completely disoriented
doesn't that sound familiar it's just
like building your new business it's
just like trying to transform your body
it might be just like this brand new
relationship you've got and in fact the
people around them are in danger in the
beginning when you give these little
guys this bat maybe that sounds familiar
maybe right now you're at this stage in
your business or you've been there
before where there's been more damage
done than there's been progress
you know what I'm talking about the
people around you have been more hurt by
your new Venture than benefited from it
your relationship with them is not as
good maybe financially you've hurt them
or feel like you have there's been a lot
of damage but what do we do with these
little guys we eventually take the
little girl or little boy and we point
them in the right direction at the
pinata that's when you find Ed mylett's
podcast you find his teachings you find
his YouTube channel or someone like me
and I can point you in the right
direction and then one of these guys
they take the bat and they're hitting
the pinata as hard as they can and
they're hitting it and they're hitting
it and they're hitting it and no candy
comes out and they get tired don't they
and they just they can't go anymore so
what do you do you get help
and you add a teammate you add a friend
you take the blindfold off of you and
you get a little help that help could be
a new recruit in your business a new
employee a new vendor it might be a new
mentor and we put the blindfold on them
we spin them around and then they're
disoriented they're swinging they're not
even hitting the pinata yet they're
they're hurting the people around them
then what do we take them we point them
in the right direction now they're
following my show or great teachings and
they hit the pinata as hard as they can
no candy comes out
you take another child new teammate new
recruit in life right but in the pinata
says another child you put a blindfold
spin them around and they hit the pinata
and they're hitting it as hard as they
can and it feels like no progress is
being made no candies coming out right
and then eventually they're getting it
and hitting they get tired and you think
man how often they think this pinata
what happens is sometimes the first few
kids who hit the pinata they kind of
disappear from the party and start
playing somewhere else maybe you've had
that experience in your business some of
the people you start with they may not
finish before the candy comes out they
may not be there may not be there to
celebrate right some of the initial
people disappear and that could cause
you to want to quit but eventually what
happens with that pinata even though
these kids are hitting the pinata and
they're teaming up they're all working
together to try to make this candy come
out it doesn't look like it but each
shot on that pinata is putting them
closer to the candy even though it
doesn't seem like it even though you
can't see the candy every blow is like a
compound pounding effect that pounding
compounded by most multiple people
eventually can create a breakthrough
but what most people do is they leave
the party before the candy comes out
that's true in business most people quit
before the candy comes out they don't
stick around long enough they got spun
around they get disoriented they might
hurt the people around they get pointed
in the right direction they think
they're making progress then they don't
they think they're making progress then
they don't and eventually because no
Candy's coming out no money no change
body no amazing relationship they stop
swinging the bat at the pinata but if
you stick around for the party long
enough you know what always happens with
a pinata eventually someone hits it and
Bam the candy comes out everywhere and
everyone celebrates and gets all the
candy and Dives on it and celebrates
here's what I'm here to remind you of
today you got to stick around long
enough for the candy to come out you
gotta wait for the candy to come out of
that pinata called your life called your
business called your body called your
relationships the vast majority of
people in life don't stick around for
the candy because they think as they're
hitting the pinata of their life they
they don't think they're making progress
it doesn't feel like progress but I'm
telling you the number one ability is
availability and if you keep swinging
away every day even though it doesn't
feel like it you are getting closer to
the candy you're getting closer it just
doesn't feel like it you know what I had
I had the ability to keep hitting the
pinata in my life to stick around long
enough and by the way when you
eventually win it's not just you that
gets all the candy that gets all the
victory that gets all the money lots of
people around you many of which who you
were hurting originally with that bat
many of them who were trying to talk you
out of it they get to celebrate in the
candy too my prayer for you
is that you begin to think about this
analogy the pinata of your life the
pinata of your business the pinata of
your body is you're swinging away I'm
here to tell you even though it doesn't
feel like it you're getting closer to
the candy and if you can add more people
to celebrate it's okay that you feel
disoriented it's okay that it feels
blinding and you don't know exactly what
direction to go just like these precious
babies with the pinata it's okay that
you miss it once in a while it's okay
that you get tired once in a while but
as long as you keep after it you keep
pounding away that compound effort of
your pounding I can promise you there's
candy someday and everybody around you
will jump on it and celebrate that's my
wish for you today as you listen to me
of all the skills I'm going to teach you
that I've taught you and if you've not
listened to my other shows I teach about
listening transfer energy how to close
how to change your identity how to live
blissfully dissatisfied how to unlock
your success code all of the very
detailed things I teach today is the
most important thing is that as you
learn all these skills
it'll help you with the blindness every
single skill you learn you'll see
clearer and clearer and clearer but if
you don't develop the talent the number
one skill in the world which is to keep
hitting the pinata and to stick around
until the candy comes out because here's
the deal
someone's gonna get the candy in life
there's always candy in life that pinata
eventually always breaks down do you
want to be the person who was there in
the beginning hitting as hard as you
could and sacrifice it and maybe hurting
the people around you
and never get the candy
or are you going to get something for
your pain are you going to get something
for your effort are you going to get
something for this sacrifice you're
making you got to get something for this
pain you got to stick in the game until
the candy comes out and then we all get
to celebrate that's what I want you
focused on today I promise you there's a
pinata in your life and right now many
of you feel blind and disoriented maybe
even hurting the people around you some
of you are past that phase and you're
hitting your thing hard every day but
there's no candy yet I promise you
there's going to be a payoff for you
speech number five is stop limiting
yourself with Alex hermosi a lot of
people struggle with this which is
they believe that they are inherently
bad at things because they are not good
at them
and I think that that is an incredibly
dangerous belief set to have and so what
I want to do is kind of break that
belief sit down to hopefully break it
for you so I think one of the most
valuable beliefs because you know in
terms of building on success in my
opinion first you need to develop skills
that need to develop character traits to
make sure that you do those skills and
then you have to make sure that your
beliefs are correct so that you can open
up the world right but the beliefs are
kind of imbued throughout the entire
process because if you don't believe you
can acquire a skill you never will right
if you don't believe you're gonna have a
character trait you never will
and so
um I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine who's
um looking to you know switch career
paths you're trying to figure out she
wasn't making as much money she wanted
to make
and the issue
um that she was dealing with she was
like she just doesn't have a valuable
enough skill set right and she's like I
want to make this much money and I was
like well you're never going to do that
doing what you're doing right
um and I was like have you considered
learning how to sell right I mean
because if you sell you have a far you
know if you still have the desire for
security but if you know how to sell you
can you know pretty much write your own
paycheck if you know where to look and
um she was like I'm not I'm not good at
sales I'm not a salesperson and I was
like well how many hours of sales
training have you gone through it was
like oh you know none and I was like
well then why would it be reasonable for
you to be good at sales
right like that doesn't that doesn't
make any sense of course you're not good
at sales like you haven't done it right
well it's so it's the same thing like
well I'm not a very marketing type
person I was like well how many courses
have you gone through how many hours a
day do you spend studying marketing well
you know none well then why is it
reasonable that like why would it it
would be unreasonable for you to be good
at this skill given the amount of
investment you've made right and so it's
this it's this recurring thing that I've
seen over and over and over again
um and it also it presents itself in
different ways like I you know I'll
speak at some event or something and
I'll start getting into very basic math
about about business just business math
like you know how much does it cost to
acquire customer how much what's the
lifetime value things like that and I
can see people starting to freak out
because they're like I'm not good at
math
and I have to lean back and our lean you
know pressure onto that belief because
one that's a belief that will literally
never serve you it's like saying like I
hate employees it's like well good luck
owning a business that you want to grow
to any appreciable scale right
um but with the math example most you
can you can you can massively succeed in
business knowing only out like not even
algebra just basic multiplication
subtraction division like if you just
know how to do that that's all you need
to do and just about everyone knows how
to do those things and at the very least
has a calculator who can do
multiplication division at addition and
subtraction that's it that's all you
literally need and the thing is is that
people mistake
that they are bad at math
when in reality they do not understand
the concepts that create the math
right cost per acquisition right okay
that's a math statement just expressed
in words and so everyone gets tripped up
and then they say I'm bad at math when
in reality they just don't understand
the term and by doing that they
inherently limit themselves from
learning because they have this checkbox
in their head that as soon as it gets
difficult they say ah I'm bad at this I
am bad at this I identify with being
poor at this thing and therefore will
never succeed at this thing that's a
requirement for being successful
and so
I think that for me one of the
Cornerstone beliefs that I that that has
helped me a tremendous amount I just
want to share it with you is that
um if someone can therefore I can
and sure is that does that necessarily
mean that you're going to you know go to
the go to go to Mars it's like no one's
ever done that before I think that's a
Next Level belief no one's ever done it
and I'm gonna be the first right but I
think if you can at least just believe
that if someone has done it it is
therefore possible and therefore I can
do it too if I do the same things and
the nice thing about actions is that
they are agnostic to your level of
deservingness and skill
what I mean by that is if you spend an
hour a day practicing sales
over a year you will likely be in the
top
ten percent five percent two percent of
people because most people do nothing
most people do absolutely nothing except
for deal with their emotions on a
regular basis and procrastinate and give
themselves reason for why they are not
successful besides the obvious one which
is that it is not reasonable that they
would be successful given the amount of
time and effort they've put in to
achieving it and so
um I the only reason for this is because
I had that conversation I spoke at The
Mastermind where the girl talked about
uh not understanding the math
um I I and just there's just so many
repeated of you know events like this
where it's like can you ask yourself
with reason would it be reasonable for
me to be good at this skill given the
investment I've made and uh as a
corollary as an antithesis to that
example I've got an 18 year old kid who
lives across the street from me
um and I sort of you know semi-mentor
him
um he's a good kid he works super hard a
lot of hustle and the thing is is he's
too young to know that he can't do
things yet
and what that does is it makes them
incredibly dangerous because he hasn't
been slapped in the face by the world
yet and so he believes that he can
accomplish anything he has no reason to
think otherwise and so I've been
actively trying to speak that into him
um and now he's he's wholesaling real
estate right now he's 18 years old right
uh I love this right and how did he do
it he watched YouTube videos for free
right and then he picked up cold calling
because I was like this is a book you
need to read for cold calling and so he
just started cold calling based on what
the YouTube videos said off of a free
list that he found on the internet and
he closes for a steal as 18 year old and
so does he have an inherent skill no but
what I did was I prepared him mentally
by saying like you're going to suck at
this for a very very long time and
eventually after doing it so many times
it will be unreasonable for you to suck
and at that point you will be good right
and so I think if we can all approach
the skills that we feel like we are
deficient in with that kind of concept
of of course I am going to suck it would
not be reasonable for me to be good
but if I do these actions it would over
time be unreasonable for me to be bad at
these things and I think by doing that
you unlock a different ability to learn
and by extension grow and so anyways I
hope you find this valuable uh it's just
it's a belief set that I find repeated
especially in people who are smaller
business owners who are getting started
Etc and it drives me nuts because it's
just saying that you can't do something
before you've even started and that's
why people spend so long in in the
beginner stages because they they
inherently dispel away their ability to
learn and get better because say well
I'm not good at that well obviously
you're not good at that you have not
done it duh speech number six is live
life with intention with Brendan
burchard if you don't feel this day it's
very likely tomorrow you're gonna be
like I don't feel purpose
and you forgot that feeling the moments
of life that's presence
is part of purpose
and to feel them even more you bring an
intention to it
right to feel the day you have to have
the intention to feel the day right
intention precedes feeling
but most people don't know that they
have a feeling then set an intention
I don't like this feeling I'm going to
change
but when you become more conscious you
say oh I'm I'm going to enter this next
situation intentional it asks what is it
that I would love to experience or make
happen
in this next moment
oh I'm gonna go play with the kids or
I'm gonna go teach my kids math okay
I'm gonna teach my kids math let me not
just show up plop the book down look at
me go what are we doing but instead save
yourself okay
I'm about to go teach my kid Matt
I like to do that as a parent
how would I like to show up
what would I like that learning
experience to feel like between us
father and son mother and daughter
what would what do I want that to feel
like
even if they don't learn well today
what do I want the end
of our learning session to feel like
for them
what Association do I want them to
create
with learning math today
now notice that took me I think I
clocked it right just under 30 seconds
to ask those questions of myself
intentional living doesn't take that
much longer it's like a beat before
going into situation
you know let me
take a second here
to enter the situation more
intentionally
that is the process of bringing purpose
to a situation
right now I'm using and replacing the
word intention with purpose for a
specific reason because people get all
lost in Airy Fairyland when they talk
about purpose but ultimately purpose
looks a lot like daily intention
and the more daily intention you have
research shows the more you say you have
a purposeful life
notice it doesn't say you earn more
built more did more it says the more
daily intention you have
the more you sense your life is
purposeful
that's pretty profound isn't it
you know you're going to go on date
night with your spouse or your partner
the person who you're you know having a
great time with or who you need to
repair with before you go go okay
we're going to have dinner tonight what
would be a purposeful experience there
you know we haven't laughed a lot lately
let me let me let me lighten the air a
little bit let me make some jokes
uh you know we haven't been getting
along lately so let me take them to
their favorite place tonight
you know what it's been a little bit
difficult with the finances lately let
me find an inexpensive way that we can
go out and have a picnic and make it
incredible
it's about and see you're you're going
about life anyway right you're going to
teach the math anyway you're gonna go to
dinner anyway
one experience is showing up going
through the motions reactionary
and the other is purposeful I'm going to
make this session of learning math
purposeful to our relationship and to
this young child's experience of
learning
we're going to go to dinner anyway
what I'm going to do is make sure that
the dinner feels like something
so that we can have a better quality
relationship so that maybe I can take
the stress off my spouse's day maybe I
can make her laugh
maybe we can go somewhere and have more
variety
you know we we have to think of the way
that we're going to do things in advance
that's purposeful being more intention
into each situation of life more
presence while you're there
repeat
okay yeah I've tried probably you'll be
stunned you'll be stunned that will make
you better at everything that you do but
also have the added benefit
of increasing the odds that you feel
that your life has purpose
so please
get that that means you're cultivating
purpose you're choosing purpose
you're imbuing moments with purpose
that what I love about that is it puts
who in the driver's seat a little bit
here
it puts yourself back in the driver's
seat so you can cultivate the feelings
you want to experience of life
you know if you don't feel that you're
getting that Divine daily instant
incredible download of purpose then
you've got to do some work
of your own
make self-improvement wave life more
intention more presence in the
situations of life and I want you to do
that at your work too I know many of you
are high performers you're out there
just crushing it but a lot of it turns
to reaction if you're not thoughtful
okay for me example I'm not a person who
loves email at all
so I literally have to pre-frame my mind
with intention and presence to do email
so when I go to do email before I sit
down I set a clock how long do I have to
do email usually it's on my calendar
tells me where to go but if not I'll be
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do 45
minutes right now
I'll clear the desk I'll put on the
headphones
I'll go through my music album and I'll
pick something that might land around 45
minutes
I'll hit play I'll hit that timer
and I will do that 45 minute power
session of email
Now by telling myself
I'm going to keep it simple I'm going to
focus I'm going to enjoy the process by
listening to music and I'm only gonna do
it for 45 minutes
by doing that for 20 years
you don't hear me complain about doing
email very often
does that make sense
because I just taught myself it's going
to get done I'm going to make myself
enjoy the process I'm going to put this
this is an intentional way of doing it
when I was miserable
doing email it was when I was random and
I was just like oh I don't know what I'm
doing
um organized project I'm not going let
me just click over to answer some emails
when I was randomly doing it there was
misery there
higher intention
a less misery
and I really want you all to think about
that your next call
your next meeting with your team
entering with a little bit more energy
of intention
I promise it just like you feel like you
take the Reigns back of life
it's a really incredible experience and
speech number seven the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is get
things done with Tom bilyu never retreat
[Music]
never explain
get it done and let them howl
[Music]
and that's the point get it done do the
thing
the accomplishment is what you're after
the performance is your opportunity
it doesn't matter what other people
think it doesn't matter if they want you
to win it doesn't matter if they
actively want you to lose what matters
is building that set of skills becoming
capable of doing the thing and in doing
the thing you will Silence the Critics
it's the man in the arena who knows that
he's showing up with the abilities that
he has to do that
question is
prepare the question is will you do the
work the question is will you be able to
get the thing done and everybody spends
their time focused on what other people
think instead of realizing the only
thing that matters is how good you get
right now I want everybody listening to
this the only thing that matters is how
good you get that's the point
the purpose of all of the all of this
don't worry about what people think
[Music]
just get so good that you can't be
denied get so good that you can't be
stopped get so good that your
performance speaks for itself if you get
that good
my friends you and you alone control
your life
if you are honest with yourself about
where you are
and you know exactly where you want to
go
you can go anywhere
[Music]
when you're going on a long car trip you
take your car to the mechanic first
right to get things recalibrated
realigned and ready to go that's our
second M how we're going to recalibrate
for our new journey is to adjust our
self-awareness neuroscientist David
Eagleman says that as far as our brains
are concerned as adults we are more like
our peers than our childhood selves yeah
when we think about who we are we mostly
base our ideas on our younger self so
tune up your self-awareness you're going
to go on a data Gathering Expedition
among those who know you best Simon
sineg the author of start with Y has a
great exercise for this when people say
I don't know what I'm good at or I don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right there's a saying that you
can't read the label from inside the job
so you're going to ask people outside
your jar to help you out can you help me
you're going to ask three to five people
who know you well it may be personal
professional friends to describe for you
what makes you special ask them Simon
recommends why are you friends with me
why did you pick me as your partner or
what makes me stand out as an employee
what do you really like about me as your
parent now beware most people will
answer first with something general
you're smart you're funny you're a good
listener that's not deep enough anything
else ask for more for example lots of
people are funny why are you friends
with me instead of someone else who's
funny or lots of employees are dedicated
can you give me more detail like a
specific incident or example that really
showed you that tell me more then you
start getting the truly helpful data and
information such as I love the way you
use humor to make other people feel
welcome and comfortable or you have this
ability to take our discussions Deeper
by bringing in insights from lots of
other fields that's very nice of you to
say you start to see yourself through
others eyes and get an understanding of
what's working what your strengths are
that you can go deeper on and maximize
and What Makes You uniquely you here's
an awesome idea convene a feel-good
Roundtable in person or over Zoom with a
few good friends or family members or
even do this with co-workers where you
go around and tell each other some of
your greatest strength in detail then
you're spreading the love and the joy
and the support as well and it doesn't
feel as awkward as just asking it for
yourself please don't make this awkward
for me okay so what else do we need to
start a journey strong we need some idea
of where we're going right a map that's
our third M you've just learned about
all these great things you've got going
for you but no doubt you also have an
area of two or twelve that's me where
you'd like to grow so we're going to
create a map of how to get there and one
way you can do that is to pick a mentor
someone who embodies that quality or
those qualities you're looking to grow
this year one of my greatest mentors is
Martin Luther King Jr specifically the
way he inspired people for a meaningful
cause and connected people to his
powerful words maybe if you want to
become better at relating to others your
Mentor is Oprah Winfrey maybe if you
want to be more strategic and thoughtful
when it comes to business it's your
father or mother that was the case for
John Mackey founder of Whole Foods his
father was his business Mentor for years
maybe if you want to cultivate
Innovation or persistence your Mentor is
someone like Sir James Dyson or Richard
Branson next figure out basic simple
ways to connect with your Mentor
regularly if it's not someone you can
connect with in real life you can read
their work watch their videos listen to
a podcast read about their lives tape an
inspiring fact about them or quote from
them above your desk or put it into your
wallet remember it's not that you want
to mimic your Mentor you want to be
yourself and combine those strands
you're developing with those great
strengths you already have in place but
if you look at some of the geography
your Mentor has traveled it can help
provide you with your own map for
developing those strengths it's a
purpose larger than yourself that keeps
you going if it's only to meet your own
needs you will drop back into your
comfort zone but like you know for
example you know one of the great things
that came out of covid is I've spent
most of my My Life as a vagabond because
I travel all over the Earth so in most
years I travel to you know 115 cities
and as you know most my seminars are
multi-day seminars and I go to 12 to 16
countries you know like Australia three
times and so all of a sudden covet hits
and I had to adapt I found this way to
adapt and now I'm reaching 10 dogs I
mean my largest seminars now 900 000
people versus fifteen thousand I was
trying I did one football stadium in
2019 with 38 000 people 40 000 people it
was incredible now that's a tiny seminar
you know because I couldn't buy 900 000
people in any Stadium right so all this
good comes from that adaptation right
figuring out what to do but I think the
other part of it is you know during that
same time when the great gifts was I
could find a way to be home and still
touch people's lives so deeply and do it
in a way that was impactful I could see
it and feel it in their home I could see
their children I mean it's been amazing
and now I do both I do hybrid I got a
thousand people in front of me and 197
countries all around me but one of the
other benefits was is we'd want to have
a daughter and I told my wife I'm not
having a kid after 50. I don't want to
show up at high school reunion and be 70
years old but now I gotta I got a night
I've got a 48 year old daughter and a
nine month old daughter give you an idea
I got five years of my granddads but my
daughter like all the things I've ever
done for myself biohacking and health
and all that stuff like now I'll be 80
at her High School reunion so I I gotta
use these things for a different reason
and so that doesn't let me get to a
certain level and stand there it's like
man I you know I thought it'd be 92 to
102 range in order to do that I got to
know every tool in the tool book to turn
around so gave me even more drive and
then what comes out of that now is I can
help anybody I mean you know this is my
new book by the way it's called life
force
February the 8th but you can pre-order
it now on Amazon or go to Tony
robbins.com but the point is it's like I
want to know every single tool like I
got totally obsessed even more than I
normally am because it's like okay I got
a higher purpose I got all my grandkids
all my children but now I got my
daughter it's like I gotta have these
tools the Dallas Uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into countless
Ubers and some small percentage of them
know who I am and then of course they
start asking questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's in
this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline
and it is humbling
and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back and how much pain people
feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life
and so I'm talking to this person about
the talk show I hang up the phone and
this Uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh I can't believe you're in my
cab and I'm like why and he says because
I I want to talk to you about something
I think you can help me and I'm like
great how can I help you and he says I
have a dream of being a oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and Latino men to do the
same in acting and I'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
Dallas right yeah the guy's 25 and so I
I go you know the game is in New York
and L.A I mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in Dallas
but why are you not in La why are you
not in New York and he's like you're
right you're right you're right I need
to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account and I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves to
change your life you have to be willing
to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be Fable be willing
as you will stay stuck forever I was
doing an Instagram live yesterday with a
young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of this what it is you're
afraid of being judged and so we're not
comfortable doing that thing you'll
you'll fail if nobody else sees it if
it's just you but you don't want to fail
in front of other people and that can no
longer be a good enough reason because
if you only do think about this if you
only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what do
what you've always done you're going to
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you again that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I had to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is the thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
as that's not against your value system
right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want him to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 when we hit
23 cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour and instead
of just doing a small tour of three
cities or something like 23 cities 90
days you know a quarter of the year on
the road straight with with my wife and
my cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things
the willingness to show up even if you
don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck
photocopying your life today looked the
same as yesterday looked the days the
day before same as the day before is why
most people do not like their life is
why most people drive to a job that they
hate
they're driving to a job to the hate
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing now try to get to the
reason behind the reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
have the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we were afraid of when people won't
watch it and what does that mean you
know that you suck and the people will
watch it and laugh at you or criticize
you for having a bad phone bad camera
bad microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
of failure if it's fear of not being
good enough if there's fear of being
imposter if it's fear of being
uncomfortable whatever your actual fear
is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
so catch what your trigger word is and
I'd love to even know in in the comments
below if you want to leave what is your
trigger word that when you say it when
you text it when you think it when you
feel it that has been holding you back
and that you no longer wanted to
so let's put it in the chat and let's
relieve
a little bit of that pressure that that
word holds over us
so you can actually go build the life
that you want
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
some powerful habits to start every day
with check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there but if
there's something inside of you that is
restless for that next level we're gonna
have to start measuring if you don't
measure it you can't improve it you know
if you ever try to lose weight or gain
you've noticed apparently this is
weightlifting talk